these cars form a convoy of sorts
a desperate procession of people who
have decided to flee
their residence of the port of mariopol
their home a city of death and despair
but it will require all their earthly
courage to leave it
in one do-it-yourself convoy the even
off family drive through the outskirts
of the city now controlled by the
russian military
father ivan is at the wheel
their sons fat sits in the back
his mother speaking for many evacuees
says life in mario paul isn't worth
living
having failed to capture this city the
russian military has decided to
pulverize it instead these pictures
taken with the even off family's camera
and the city's three-story theater has
been targeted in a strike this house of
culture serving as a refuge as the
russians encircled the city
there were hundreds of people sheltering
inside crammed into the stalls and the
corridors these pictures taken in the
theater before the attack
the authorities say they are trying to
dig survivors out of the rubble
the drama theater was hit by
a russian strike
one thousand possibly one thousand two
hundred people taking shelter inside i
think it was
more
was badly unprepared says christina
there was nowhere to go few basements to
take shelter in
the family spent two weeks on the ground
floor of a local school
and they had no water and there was
little food to go around
with no services or power the residents
of marriott are forced to make do
wooden cots from a kindergarten are
stripped for fuel
but it is a dangerous business spending
time outside in a city that suffers from
constant shelling
um
we found the even offs in the city of
dinique pro 300 kilometers to the north
they couldn't bring their loved ones
with them their parents would not travel
but their nine-year-old boy is safe and
well
were there times where you felt scared
or frightened
the battle for mario paul continues to
rage
although the russians claim they do not
target ukrainian towns and cities
but the ivanovs want the world to know
what they've been through
their home is more than 300 kilometers
from here but in a way they'll never
leave it
john sparks sky news in dinipro